come here
okay my dad is taking me to lunch for
her meeting I'm so excited I love going
to lunch meetings thank you much yeah
they found me again I don't know how so
weird but I guess we decided to walk
home
great idea it's so hot I don't know what
we're gonna do next because I didn't
know I had a day off so we'll figure
something out I'm kind of just like
chill marks is like let's do something
we'll see who wins
oh what's that
okay you brought gift yeah okay
no it's all right I'll take them I can't
open this gate though that's right oh
Christ wanted to give you guys thank you
so much that's sweet thank you that's
really nice hey breakfast thank you nice
meeting you bye such a sweet letter it's
really nice hi we're getting gifts I'm
always worried that it's gonna get too
far with too many people you know
because a lot like that guy totally knew
he got it but you know some people come
by and they'll start yelling outside and
be crazy no one wants that we're at
Griffith oh they have free Wi-Fi well
then this is my new favorite place I am
so tired I don't know why we didn't even
walk up here I've been here before I did
a shooting here but I never got to check
it out so I'm glad I can show Marzia oh
look guys there's the Hollywood sign
again the Hollywood sign is right there
don't you see it way too easily apprendi
impressed the smog really does the trick
that thing will like show the time and
date based on the shadow but that thing
I want to go down and check it out see
it says on it like June May Aires I
don't know how it works but it goes all
the way up if you know how it works let
me know because I'm curious
Shh all the way across to the thing is
okay going down oh it is what do we get
I knew the air from all around me
Wow it's gonna allow you so Tesla wanted
to have free energy for everyone in the
world so he built this thing where
people would get wireless energy
Galileo's telescope
this is sunlight coming from there like
a 10 probably not a good idea you see
that can you see the heart no it's right
there there's yeah there's the Mercs and
this is the heart in your money just
fake like we just hit the button to
published legend of the brofist it
should be available in like an hour a
fan came by and gave me this so I'm
guessing it says super extreme spice
thank you much
oh they are really red aren't they come
on America is that all you got
use like baby spicy oh I just got in my
throat all right all right I'm gonna
build a smartphone controlled paper
airplane YouTube / youtube [ __ ] a suck
dick for views
you want me you [ __ ] what me maximum
speed
bear [ __ ] work
you [ __ ] what hey breakfast Rufus
what are you doing here I'm sorry it's
all right Marcus a bro is helping me
film this yeah cos II think this is
gonna work would you get that today yeah
I think so okay you say your girlfriend
was in the car yeah well I can go and
say hi she locked her in the car
nice one dude thanks for the gift oh my
good brofist yes I wonder how you're
shorter than I thought so
oh come on so that you bought this bike
because he saw Edgar yeah that's awesome
okay so he wasn't actually trying to
stalk me he was just trying to sneak a
package which I can respect I know a lot
of people get pissed when fans get too
close and I get pissed too but if people
literally just want to drop a package I
don't have a problem okay well this is
awesome
yes I'm literally wearing same bread oh
yes might say you'll be happy about this
bug spray I'm heading out now actually I
gotta get ready I'm at this place
waiting for two scrubs for late typical
youtuber hello and welcome to the pie
this will be my tentacle for this
evening I don't want to eat it like you
usually do it do it you can't [ __ ] out
now there you go fill those suckers in
your tongue it's good really good it's
really good
you guys are waiting
we're setting you up fire baby
yes I don't want to drink the Cuddy
you don't you're out okay
are you serious just blow it I can't see
you I can't see myself I don't know
what's going on who are you what if I
you're blowing now okay
welcome to eat you pay today yes YouTube
life oh look at Metallica
that's Metallica right yes okay I'm done
all right guys I'm just gonna go okay
okay just relax just your flag yes it is
traveling to San okay okay a little
before just let you come here oh all
right I just came back really fun to me
to have an immunity and he's got a lot
of good times this is a in the vlog hope
you enjoyed 100%
breakfast ready God feel good